le rendez-vous que nous vous proposons à
vous élus des collectivités
territoriales autour du principe d'État
généraux des collectivités territoriales
c'est de savoir un peu où nous en sommes
par rapport à la décentralisation nous
savons depuis 2003 que l'organisation de
la République est décentralisée
aujourd'hui faut-il aller plus loin dans
la décentralisation faut-il aller plus
loin en se disant que c'est un choix qui
est conduit entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales ou tout
simplement est-ce que l'État n'a-t-il
pas la tentation de se délester de
compétences j'allais dire pour ne plus
avoir à les financer sujet d'actualité
en ces temps de crise alors je crois
qu'il faut engager cette réflexion
autour de quatre principes quatre
principes d'abord le premier des
principes c'est la confiance confiance
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoriales je vois bien que cette
interrogation elle nous est posée
souvent comme sénateur seconde des
choses c'est comment ont rationalise
l'organisation entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales comment
mutualise et le couple commune
communauté de communes communautés
d'agglo communauté urbaine c'est une
vraie j'allais dire réalité comment on
l'a fait vivre et puis comment
rationalise et comment on sort et c'est
tout le rapport d'Éric de Ligier
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet de cet amas de
norme qui quelque part nous étouffe et
parfois à des conséquences financières
ou juridiques extrêmement importantes
pour nos collectivités avec ces
mots-clés confiance mutualisés
rationalisée j'allais dire quelque part
un peu libéré
je crois que nous pouvons ensemble
débattre c'est tout l'intérêt des
rencontres que nous aurons dans chaque
département c'est tout l'intérêt de
l'apport que vous ferez à de vrais
assises qui ne soient pas écrite à
l'avance mais qui soient écrite avec
vous par les sénateurs et notamment les
sénateurs de l'Union pour un mouvement
populaire
mais sénateur aussi de sensibilité
centrices et je crois le sens de la
rencontre que nous vous proposons